das große ganze sehen dann können wir
diese krise nicht lösen
ganzheitliche lösungsansätze sollten das
kernstück der kopf sein
stattdessen ist sie zu etwas zu
verkommen bei dem länder versuchen
schlupflöcher auszuhandeln oder ihre
verantwortung nicht anzunehmen
[Applaus]
länder finden clevere möglichkeiten
nicht zu handeln
sie zählen emissionsreduzierungen
doppelt oder betreiben emissionshandel
sie nehmen ihre versprechen zurück dass
die ehrgeizige handeln werden
sie weigern sich lösungen zu bezahlen
oder schäden zu begleichen
das muss aufhören was wir brauchen sind
drastische emissionsreduzierungen an der
quelle
doch das bloße senkung von emissionen
reicht nicht aus unsere treibhausgase
müssen ganz aufhören die ausschüttung es
ganz aufhören um unter 15 grad
erderwärmung zu bleiben muss das co2 im
boden bleiben
daten in der fernen zukunft festzulegen
und so zu tun als ob etwas getan wird
ist wahrscheinlich schädlicher als alles
andere
bei der wandel den wir brauchen nicht
greifbar ist die politischen maßnahmen
die wir benötigen gibt es heute nicht
egal was man von den politikern hört ich
glaube immer noch dass die größte gefahr
nicht
das nichtstun ist sondern wenn politiker
und sie aus zu tun als ob etwas
geschieht wenn sie eigentlich fast
nichts tun als zahlen clever zu drehen
und schlauer pr maßnahmen auf den weg zu
bringen
[Applaus]
ich hatte das große glück dass sich die
welt bereisen konnte und meiner
erfahrung nach ist es so dass überall
der gleiche mangel an bewusstsein
herrscht und das betrifft auch die
staats und regierungschefs es gibt kein
gefühl für dringlichkeit überhaupt keine
unsere politiker verhalten sich nicht so
als ob wir uns in einem notstand
befinden
in einem notstand verändert man doch
sein verhalten wenn ein kind in der
mitte der straße steht und autos mit
voller geschwindigkeit auf uns zurasen
guckt man doch auch nicht weg weil es
unbequem ist
nein man sprintet auf das kind zoom es
zu retten ohne dieses gefühl der
dringlichkeit wie können wir die
menschen da verstehen dass wir vor einer
echten krise stehen wenn die menschen
sich nicht wirklich bewusst sind was
geschieht dann werden sie die mächtigen
nicht unter druck setzen damit diese
handeln und ohne druck der bevölkerung
werden die mächtigen einfach nichts tun
können und damit durchkommen das ist der
status quo
das wird immer wieder so ablaufen
in drei wochen beginnt ein neues
jahrzehnt ein jahrzehnt dass unsere
zukunft bestimmen wird im moment
klammern wir uns bezweifelten jedoch die
zeichen der hoffnung
ich sage euch es gibt hoffnung ich habe
sie gesehen aber sie kommt nicht von den
regierungen oder unternehmen
sie kommt aus der bevölkerung von den
menschen die menschen die sich nicht
bewusst waren die nicht bescheid wussten
doch die jetzt aufwachen und wenn das
passiert dann verändert sich das
verhalten menschen können sich ändern
die menschen sind bereit sich zu ändern
das ist unsere hoffnung weil wir
demokratie haben
demokratie passiert die ganze zeit nicht
nur wenn gewählt wird sie passiert jede
sekunde jede stunde
es ist die öffentliche meinung die die
freie welt regiert jeder große wandel in
der geschichte kam aus der bevölkerung
wir müssen nicht warten
wir können den wandel jetzt anstoßen wir
die bevölkerung vielen dank